what do you think about mechanical
warrior robots in the SEAL Teams again
this is this is a question where people
ask me this because there's weird hype
and what's the word conspiracy type
attitude about you know artificial
intelligence and robots and all that and
so my thoughts are robots like war
fighting robots awesome let's build the
most awesome destruction robots and
let's build an army of them and let's
let them get after it I think it's
awesome you look what's happening right
now with drones and unmanned air
vehicles that's where we're going in
another I forget the name I may forget
this specific time frame but in 10 20 30
years there's not gonna be any more
manned fighter jets military fighter jet
so why would you do that you can put a
computer in there and you can fly it
from the ground or you can even need to
quiet it'll do it your mission that you
want it to do so when we can come up
with a robot the Terminator robot that
can go and attack and take care of the
problem yeah let's do that I support it
I hate the whole idea that robots will
turn against us we'll build better
robots that will kill those robots I'm
not worried about that
robots yeah I don't care I say bring it
on bring on the robots yeah I'll crush
you yes I know like Joe Rogan you'd be
freaking out about some robots you know
and I think you know pretty much
everybody I'm probably the ignorant
person here right because the smart
people like Elon Musk in Sam Harris
they're all you know you gotta watch out
because this artificial intelligence is
gonna become smarter than us and then
what are you gonna do it's gonna attack
us and control us yeah their thing is if
if if it winds up that they'd they'd
ultimately figure out and they won't be
wrong is that's the that's the view if
they figure out that they don't need us
then the logical thing would be to
eliminate us yeah like like everybody
and everything does ever you know yeah I
got to admit like
that sounds pretty cool I say bring it I
want that robot war well typically
robots I mean we say unmanned
hey how about we unplug them right cut
their power source
yeah but typically I mean even that when
you you know yeah I don't think it I
think this you I think that's a simple
thing for a robot if they're smart to
understand oh they might very well cut
off our power source so they're gonna
figure that out pretty quick I would
imagine if they're turning but I like
the way Sam Harris described artificial
intelligence at one time though he said
imagine that you that I asked you a
question and then you have a year to go
and research and come up with the
perfect answer and then you come back
and you answer that question but it
happens in a millisecond that's what a
computer's gonna be able to do yeah and
that's pretty awesome yeah and do they
end up then and I don't know you know
I'm not a I don't even know what you'd
call a person that fee Rises about this
kind of thing I'm not one of them Martin
but that's pretty unbelievable and and
it'll only get faster and better from
there and I just think that I don't
think it's too hard to control to put
controls in there that prevent the the
turning of the robots like preventative
mechanisms yeah well you talk about
unmanned stuff and you can oh no you
know what I'm about to make a movie
reference hit oboe cop hit it Robocop
it's cool I think the story of that had
some kind of a mechanism out there the
directive the directive render prime
directive wasn't allowed to kill wait
what is a prime directive what's that
from that from Robocop I think so I know
they're up uphold the law protect the
innocent this I'm not doing it in order
something about trust see if you were AI
you'd be able to come back with a
perfect answer you know but you program
in that you can't hurt humans or
whatever right whatever like this real
thing let's let's this is another
situation let's see where it goes
I'm good but the unmanned thing I mean
it's based on like patterns you know so
the unmanned thing usually you're not
gonna find something that's really
technically unmanned even a drone is the
unmanned it's just less they can be on
it's just less money
well yeah somebody programmed that where
to go but you can put a drone in the sky
that's gonna go yeah but see what you
say you can put some ones that I put
them in in the sky someone's gotta
launch somebody so it's gonna be manned
like the intentions of something like
that first intention of something's
gonna be manned first once you give that
up then you're like okay now you got
some problems yeah you know yeah again i
i'm just not sitting around worried
about this kind of thing so I'll let Joe
Rogan and Sam Harris yeah an Elon Musk
worried about keeping the robots in line
you know what I'll be ready to I'll be
ready to fight him if they if they need
me
bring it yep sure